[Music]
foreign
spee
for
[Music]
foreign
keep
go
forus
I'm telling you it's going to be another
hot one out there in fact there are heat
alerts in effect for New Jersey feeling
like a 100
[Music]
De what is
that
you
for the first time in New York history
people froze to death in the middle of
July what is it the death
chill the power to kill by fear
itself your veins turn to rivers of ice
your bones crack and the last thing you
see is your own tear ducts freezing
up like literally scared to death so
[Music]
cool
for
Fore
fore
[Music]
4 years ago I was basically
unemployed a Wanderer with no
home but now I'm a husband and a
father and I wouldn't have it any other
way
I know how you do it pops my job was a
little less stressful than
yours oh yeah I finally got a job I'm
the king of
[Music]
Atlantis half a billion people from
every known species in the sea call this
place
home but that isn't mean they all like
me I'm going to kill Aquaman and destroy
everything he holds
dear I'm going to murder his
family and burn his kingdom to
Ash he must be stopped or a global
meltdown is
imminent I think I know someone might be
a to help
us you look
rough
good job little brother High fire do not
call me
brother I cannot believe you let this
happen yeah well I hate this job true
king builds Bridges
right true king builds
Bridges we need to find Manta he's
different now he's stronger than
before it's the black
Trion in King alin's time there were
Seven
Kingdoms and the Trident was a curse
upon them
all the trid and start magic is
spreading he means to end the
[Music]
bloodline I don't know what lies ahead
but we can't leave our children a world
without
hope you're not as bad at this as you
think if you lead the Seven Kingdoms
will
[Music]
follow I know that I've lived a
relatively comfortable
life a
[Music]
mercy you need to go
home VA dwellers are an endangered
species I do not think you would be
willing to do what it takes to survive
up
[Music]
here if you insist on
staying then you will have to
adapt
uh-huh I don't want to
[Music]
see I
see tomorrow so they say will be a
lovely
day a bright new sun will suddenly break
through but I don't want to see
tomorrow
unless I see it with
you I grabbed a moldy
one
[Music]
I don't want to see
tomorrow I
see
[Music]
for most of human
civilization
we believed that life could only
exist on the surface of our
planet what else were we wrong
about welcome to my
world won't you
come on
in this world has more
secret than we could possibly imagine
Miracles
I
still
[Music]
now what is
that that's not
Kong
who could have done
this K can't stop this on his
own he won't be
alone
is
welcome to my
world is that a mini
Kong when I
sleep I see strange
[Music]
things
memories not
Memories new
things I see
everything that is not
[Music]
everything
what a wonderful
day
errors were made in the hours following
King maser's
death the war be
fought many will
die and the Victor will eventually
Ascend the
throne there is no war so hateful to the
Gods
there's a war between
Ken and no war so bloody as a war
between
[Music]
dragons
you deserve the
truth the
enemy is at our
gates their numbers are
overwhelming any Marine who makes this
stand with
us will not survive the
day for every moment that we hold the
enemy at
Bay more innocent people can
escape when they
do they will go forth
and tell the story that you write today
bab you will be
remembered
remember
[Music]
pereus that's me mhm that's who you're
named after because he was a hero
because he was Brave and kind and
Against All Odds he managed to find his
way to a happy
ending
I'm used to the world feeling weird to
me like a puzzle with half their own
pieces but lately it all feels different
somehow Percy you are special when
you're ready to hear what the gods have
in store for you they'll tell you Percy
the stories I have told you about great
Gods and
Monsters they are
real
this is crazy you are a half blood and
half Bloods are not safe in the world
everything has been training for what's
still ahead of
you hold
on Percy Jackson your father needs your
help the master boat has been sto if you
don't return the boat they will be war
that is your
quest I know oh it sounds
daunting but you won't be alone a quest
is always undertaken by three Dem Gods
process reality differently we got to
figure out what you're good
at should I try again no
no there's no place for me
here you still don't get where you fit
into all
this we were sent on a quest by the gods
would you think it would be easy Demi
Gods welcome
I'm not leaving you cus hold fast Brave
the
storm maybe I won't even need a
sword I'm going to need a
sword
monor was there in San
Francisco when the whole city was coming
down these guys were taking pictures
like they've been waiting for
it you think that your father was
working for them this stuff wasn't as
safe who are they what's
Monarch there's a
new com
this is the world we live in monsters
are an inescapable reality
and those files belong to us and they
are more important than you could
possibly
[Music]
imagine this is going to give me
nightmares now you can choke down on
that Monarch
lie about your father disappearing
or we can find out what really
[Music]
happened before it's too
late oh my God go go go this world it's
not ours believe
me is so much more vast than we could
possibly
imagine
com these monsters and Monarch have
taken everything from
me no
more the world is on fire if you want to
save millions of lives we can use some
help
[Music]
how does it feel being back good I had
such good memories here maybe my happy
place can be our happy place we left you
all alone down
here my
imagin I'm playing a new game with chy
scavenger hunt list that's fun Chanty
says you're not allowed to play with us
oh because you left him I need something
happy something
happy G I thought bugs freaked you out
if I can finish my list chy will take me
on a trip to the place he's
[Music]
from something that hurts
Alice
but my
imagin you've been spending time with a
new
[Music]
friend he asked you to do something that
hurt you that was part of the game does
that seem like a game a good friend
would want to play maybe we shouldn't
play together anymore johy maybe we
shouldn't be friends no no no
no Alice Alice Alice Alice Alice
Alice she's lost but we're going to find
her every culture has entities that
tether to the young we call them
imaginary
friends you are always playing with your
imaginary friend when the connection was
severed The Entity becomes
enraged he says he's right behind
you but it was just my
imagin can I hang out with your
imaginary friend he's not
imaginary and he's not your
[Applause]
friend
there's a young
man I talk to him I wish I was been
[Music]
you that's really weird
Lisa I'm the
greatest God
created powering
Taffy says it's a waste of time to try
and fix a way it's better just accept a
guy's flaws oh that's so
[Music]
cute I can't do that not until we bury
the
body there is no turning back
now I can't be
sa and in the next life they'll remember
me remember
[Music]
me really hope this goth phase in
soon
my dad he
died I'm the solicitor of your father's
estate my dad owned this
place I don't have any memories with him
this is all I have right
now if you're watching this then I'm
already
[Music]
dead this property comes with a special
tenant
you're the one thing that stands between
her and the outside world you're
joking what is that come out come out
whereever you
are
Iris we shouldn't be
here
what is
she she has the power to bring back the
Dead I want to see her money's really no
object I want to talk to my
wife she only gives you 2
minutes Sarah after that she's in
controller what's going on
we are not safe
here how do I control
her this isn't something you can
control I'm going to kill you you can't
kill
her you cannot let her out of the
basement
scared we all asleep where do we no he
didn't when we were fixing up the pool
St they said it hadn't been used in 15
years maybe they weren't pool
people this is not for the
camps used to be scared of
pools cider come on
cider get a Vibe here do you have a
boyfriend no hey someone's coming over
in a
minute keep your mouth shut Marco
you need to say something
back Ronin
Marco why aren't you saying
anything my kids have seen things and
I'm worried something is happening to my
husband Dad I've been looking for
you there has to be some way to stop
this
Marco ell
here
Marco
Marco Marco
[Music]
B
I have a job for you piece of cake
really give me
r a security
gig
hello welcome to Freddy's have you met
them
yet met
who foxy Bonnie Chica
Freddy back in the
8S some kids went missing what is this
it's why the place shut
down the police search Freddy's hey the
never found the
kiss what the
[Music]
heck ghost
children possessing giant
robots tell me how to stop
them you don't it's too
late he's
coming
fore spe
foree
fore fore
[Music]
speee
spee
[Music]
for
m so
[Applause]
[Music]
foree